mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices
over the last 18 months
i know the anguish that they have been
through
to mourn their relatives unable to live
their lives as they want or to do the
things
they love
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead
when they think that in downing street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
and though i cannot anticipate the
conclusions of the current
inquiry i have learned enough
to know that there were things
we simply
did not get right
and i must take responsibility
[Applause]
number 10 is a big department
with the gardeners as an extension of
the office
which has been in constant use because
of the role of fresh air in stopping the
virus
and when i went into that garden just
after six on the 20th of may
2020 to thank groups of staff before
going back into my office 25 minutes
later to continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
but mr speaker
with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
i should have found some other way
to thank them
and i should have recognized that
even if it could be said technically to
fall
within the guidance
there would be millions and millions of
people
who simply would not see it that way
people who suffered terribly
people who were forbidden from meeting
loved ones at all
inside or outside
and
to them and to this house i offer my
heartfelt apologies
and all i ask is that sue gray be
allowed to complete her inquiry into
that day and several others so that the
full facts can be established and i will
of course come back to this house and
make a statement
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today